غادر منتخب تونس اليوم في اتجاه الدمام
لانطلق في التحذير للامور جديه بمعسكر
يمتد الى غايه الثالثه عشر من هذا الشهر
قبل التحول الى قطر يوم الرابعه عشر من
شهر نوفمبر وكان في توديعه ثلاثه وزراء هم
وزير الرياضه ووزير النقل ووزير الشؤون
الاجتماعيه
المنتخب الوطني
قبل شهر وثلاثه اسابيع من بدايه المال
علينا
الاختيار على الدمام نعرفه للدمام قريبه
جدا حتى على مستوى الطقس على مستوى ال-
ال- الدوحه
منتخب وتونس تحول الى الدمام للاستعداد
لبقيه المشوار وذم وفد المنتخب اليوم 8
لاعبين فقط في انتظار التحاق بقيه
اللاعبين الذين ينشطون في الدوريات
الاوروبيه
حتى اليوم 14 يوم
اللاعبين اللي يلعبون
الدوري الاوروبي وقدره ربي اكتمل نساء
بيوم 14 همم
مقابل همم وديه ضد ايران يوم 16 منتخب
الثاني لاول مره في تاريخه
باذن الله ان شاء الله
نفرحهم ان شاء الله نوريهم وجهي ينور
بالشهر الشعب التونسي نعرفوا اللي جماهير
تونسيه تكون موجوده برشا في قطر هذا عامل
ايجابي بالنسبه لان احنا دزوا معنا كيف ما
شفناهم في الكوبرا ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله يكونوا فرحانين باذن الله
احنا كمجموعه باذن الله مع التركيز
والخدمه باذن الله ان شاء الله
كما قال المدرب ان شاء الله
هدف
قادرين اذا كنا ومركزين وحاضرين
باذن الله
وهكذا تنطلق الامور جديه بالنسبه للمنتخب
التونسي والبدايه بالسفر الى الدمام لخوض
معسكر تدريبيه ومنه الانطلاق الى قطر يوم
الرابعه عشر للدخول في غمار تصفيه كاس
العالم قطر 2022 من مطار تونس قرطاج
الدولي علي زريعه العربيه تونس